la journée du 6 décembre se déroule
toujours à peu près de la même façon à
l'École Polytechnique de Montréal depuis
33 ans
même si les étudiants d'aujourd'hui
n'ont aucun souvenir de la tragédie qui
a secoué leur école et tout le pays ce
jour-là en 1989 la mémoire des 14 jeunes
femmes assassinées s'impose on serait
met un peu dans l'état d'esprit que ça
commence à s’est passé à 33 ans puis
c'est quelque chose qui nous affecte ça
s'est passé dans nos corridors dans nos
classes il y a encore des féminicides il
y a encore des angles de violence il y a
encore des crimes qui sont commises avec
des armes à feu d'avoir des mémoire puis
ça a pas toujours touché la communauté
de police
en rappel Pixie un moment pour penser
aux victimes pensées aux familles un
gros mix d'émotions aujourd'hui c'est
très chargé quand même journée Sophia
roi fait un doctorat en génie chimique
marchand ici dans les traces de sa mère
arrivait à Polytechnique deux ans après
le féminicide de 89 qui a été un choc
pour elle un réveil brutal samedi il
faut voir que je sois forte pour aller
dans cette profession-là c'est pour ça
que je me suis dit en tant que jeune
fille mais j'étais convaincu c'est ça je
voulais faire puis j'adorais les
sciences mademoiselle Sofia roi
l'étudiant reçoit une bourse de 30000
dollars de l'Ordre de la Rose Blanche
créée en l'honneur des victimes de la
tuerie de Polytechnique ma vision du
futur essaie d'une société complètement
redessinée pour pallier les défis
imposés par la crise climatique sophia a
choisi le génie pour trouver des
solutions ou réchauffement de la planète
mais avec encore seulement 15% de femmes
au sein de l'Ordre des ingénieurs du
Québec elle sait qu'elle va affronter
des vents de face comme sa mère l'a fait
dans l'industrie encore des échos que
les femmes en position leadership se
font au moins écouter c'est comme encore
un peu difficile il y a des biens
conscience qui restent oui il y a des
billets conscients ou inconscients mais
je trouve que depuis 30 ans il y a
beaucoup de chemin qui était parcourus
mais c'est certain que on a encore un
petit peu de chemin à faire 17h10
[Musique]
14 jeux de lumière illumine un à eux le
ciel de Montréal
alors précise Marc l'épine avait
commencé à tirer sur des étudiantes
après avoir écarté les hommes de sa
trajectoire
l'an dernier au Canada
173 femmes ont été tués parce qu'elles
étaient des femmes une hausse de 26%
depuis le début de la pandémie ça
continue
il va falloir qu'on continue d'agir et
encore des femmes en 2022
sont violentés parfois assassinés par
leur mari donc il reste du travail à
faire on a tous une responsabilité
à chaque 6
les étudiants de Polytechnique en congé
mais beaucoup viennent quand même à
l'école participer au commémorations et
réfléchir sur cette haine qui peut
pousser un homme à tuer une femme il y a
beaucoup de travail à faire de ce
côté-là on le voit surtout le côté
prévention pour pas que justement on
réagisse à chaque fois puis on n'a pas
prévenu
des hommes pourquoi ils font ça on n'a
pas dit on comprend pas c'est
compréhensible mais peut-être faudrait
creuser là aussi
on veut des solutions mais pourquoi en
attendant de comprendre la souffrance et
la violence de certains hommes je pense
qu'elle va accomplir de grandes choses
je suis vraiment fier de toi ces
ingénieurs mère et fille espère donner
l'exemple qu'il est possible de réaliser
ses rêves
même dans l'adversité ici Sophie
Langlois Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]